all right rita hi
how are you fine because i came over
here and
welcome welcome back yeah i got a family
because
my old man is a truck driver he looks
just like you
and he lived in big ben but he visited
me every year
so so how are you doing now you're
living where i'm living
on that corner you're you're at a sri
lanka i don't know the street
yes i got a house now by my own self
and they're gonna help me with a tv
and stuff but i got bed i got everything
so you're
you're you're in you have your own room
yeah much nicer than living on the
street
yeah and they give me a full box once a
week
so you're getting treated a little
better yeah a lot better somebody must
have reported but yes
they treat me real good and when i come
here it just be all the
it that's great and you're
are you still doing things for money
that you're used to no i don't
prostitute no more
you don't y'all helped me a whole lot
yeah who helped your life
you might oh yeah you helped me yeah i
guess i did and i don't even go
panhandling for food you don't union
station nope
i don't i got food so are you much
happier now yeah
that's great you seem happier i just got
to be clean but i'm happy your hair
looks great i got
food now they gave us a full box
yesterday with real tv
dentists that's nice yeah i just want
some
under clothes and some hygiene
so so where do you think your life will
go from here you've got a nice place to
stay
i want to try to be on dancing with the
stars
you should you should try to do that i
am because i
was singing in in front of the building
a lot of people was just
happy and feeling great that's that's
telling me this thing
good to have dreams that's great yeah
because they wanted me to sing songs for
so you're a good dancer yeah you are
okay dad i i make up my own dance
yeah okay but yeah i'm happy
that's great i'm not a prostitute no
more and i'm not a beggar
i used to go to unis station and i used
to
go downtown by a grocery store
7-11 but i don't do that i did it in
two months now since i've been here
awesome yeah that's nice to hear yeah
yeah
you deserve to have a nice break in your
life you had such a rough
and then this lady had said monica
looked like my mother
and she said that i'd come and stay with
her anytime and i
she gave me some clothes she my size but
she's car cage and what
yellow hat and she gave me some clothes
that day
she fed me we went to the malls and
stuff
and yeah she took a picture
and then she gave me something so you
have some people being honest i got
it yeah these people being nice to you
hey mother yes that's saying monica i
really got it
over there at by the
broadway it's cause you're a movie star
now right yeah
i know everybody in my building say i'm
a movie star
yeah i am i nev that's why i came to
california to be on
tv to be like okay well maybe maybe i
helped you with that little dream
huh yeah you could yeah because i could
dance
yeah the dancing part i'm not sure if i
can help you with but an outcome makes
you don't i could dance good and i could
sing
i had a lot of people last night feeling
good
are you still using uh a crack sometimes
yeah you do
that's hard to get rid of god said i
gotta tell it too
yeah that's a hard drug to stop using it
yeah
but i don't go to the program it's just
when it run out
they run out but when i need things i
get them first and if i'm too tired and
stuff
i don't go hustling nothing it just done
i don't cause problems to get it no
that's serious sometimes it's nasty to
me now lately
for some reason i come here it's nasty i
feel
but you know famous i feel better than
i used to be i said
i'll be walking and they'd be wanting to
sell themselves i'd be like ah
i've got something positive to do for
forgot what
what makes you feel good having nice
clothes looking nice being close yeah
you seem to be in the clothes
being clean and like the other lady bit
looking nice
that's all they meant looking nice it's
uh
yeah and i'm gaining weight at first
you're gaining weight since yeah i eat
more since you've been helping me
i eat more i used to go two and three
days without eating just smoking crack
but i eat a lot now that's great yeah
and i don't think about crab i eat
just be like normal people sorry are you
using less crack
yeah oh you are i smoke like three times
a week
i used to smoke every day
um yeah that's great i smoked
last night but i don't got a taste for
it
that's how it ain't something i have to
do
really if i'm around people it's just
hard to be in this neighborhood
yeah because everyone's doing it yeah
because when i stopped doing it somebody
come to my door and knocking give me
stuff of course they do yeah
it's free and then when they see me next
time
they just tell me to give more money
yeah i even took a shower and nothing
because i was smoking but i'm gonna get
some clothes or something
and look pretty take a shower i'm not
gonna go to sleep though because i've
been smoking
but you're sleeping good and you're
eating good now yeah yeah okay
especially eating i used to be real
skinny bone
even they notice they say i'm gaining a
lot of
weight and you're using less crack which
i think yeah gain weight right
yeah i used to be a hundred and
fourteen now and i'm 126.
since i met you yeah because i went to
the doctor because i got
copd and when i did that corona thing
they said it's an area they didn't know
if i had it or not
so i had to go to the real hospital and
they said i didn't have it
no you seem great yeah excellent both so
i seeing you again
yeah without asking for money because
you made me feel bad now
i want to be like your friend everybody
asked me for money yeah
but without money just to be come
dressed up
i like teaching now that you helped me
get
i know my sister know and show my sister
i'm a star now
i'm on tv yeah that means i'm a star
because
this youtuber you are a star yeah thank
you
we're gonna make you famous yeah yeah my
sister said that she's happy for me
she's gonna get your manager now
she got to see for yourself yeah it
ain't just money i just want my sister
to see
um you know be clean pretty and
yeah cool uh yeah you wanna dance for me
yeah
you know i know music i don't have any
music i'm sorry next time
yeah but my sister worked for sacramento
elementary
and she's a minister and she
got a guilty moment for the girls and
she going she had to deal with dudes and
stuff too
back on tv in the phone and stuff okay
yeah so she's gonna give me a little
while i'm just starting
dizzy there you go okay
yes
hey